one of the curious things that you you
soon have to come to terms with when you
look at the life of bar is that he never
wrote an opera and that's a big
conundrum why didn't he write an opera
opera was the passport of success it was
the means of earning good living it was
the it was the really favored jar of the
day it took to make you your name in the
world and yet he he went away from it
and it was it because he never really
heard any opera that can't be the case
there were several opportunities in his
life when he could have heard opera
starting from the time when he was a an
adolescent living in lüneburg not so
very far south of Hamburg where there
was a flourishing opera house and Handel
and Madison all performed there tailor
man later but was very much involved in
it was it because he had an allergy
towards opera because he thought it was
somehow uninteresting as a genre I mean
he talks sometimes disparagingly about
those little ditties that they go on a
performed at The Dresden Opera when he
he says shall we go and hear them to his
eldest son I don't think it's anything
to do with that I think it's to do with
something much more profound which is
that opera by then I'm talking about the
early 1720 1730's had already if you
like taken a wrong turning when you
think of how fantastically innovative
opera was at its inception back in the
1600s with people like Monteverdi of all
where it was a type of through-composed
utterance in musical terms natural
speech rhythms and also closed form
dance and and the the basics of what
later became an aria by the time you get
to 1700 a just a century later it's
already started to fall into two
different categories you have all the
action packed in to rest at Eve rest at
Eve being very fast paced patter rhythms
that tell you the story the narrative
and then moments of reflection and
emotional response to the action in the
form of areas usually Da Capo areas in
the sense that you start with an a
section it goes onto a B section and you
go back to the a section I'm feeling sad
but my heart is grieving I feel still
sadder and so on I think that back
although he took quite a lot of those
conventions and turn them on their head
felt that there was something much more
profound to be expressed it through a
different form which we might call
Mutant Opera it's as though opera has
jump tracks as it were and it becomes a
kind of music drama that doesn't require
the stage it doesn't require makeup it
doesn't require wigs it doesn't require
spears and costumes and swords it simply
requires the musicians to deliver in a
very very dramatic but not theatrical
way and there's something of the fear
that was really inculcated I think in
the clergy of Bach's day in that they
said they didn't want him to compose
music that was in any way operatic or
theatrical and that was the first thing
that he the first rule that he broke
because his passions and his cantatas
are full of drama drama in the sense of
dialectic of conversations going on
between characters between two voices
between several voices between an
instrument or its several instruments
and a voice almost as though the aria
sung by an individual is being echoed or
anticipated or or contradicted even by
with whether it's a valid or an oboe or
a flute so that there's this element of
dialogue constantly a constant thread
all the way through box writing and
which I think we find is the entry point
for a composer like Mozart
Juran who picked up a lot of this
dramatic mutant operatic thread that
that bark so beautifully expressed